ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เจอกับครูเอ๋กับครูฟ้าอีกแล้วนายร้ากิน
เนอะมีกินหน้าคะน่ารักนะคะรูปภาพก่อนเข้า
ท็อปปิดวันนี้วันอะไร
นะคะได้ค่ะ
วันเกิดได้ไหมคะโอเคได้ๆ
วันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 25 ค่ะวันที่ 25
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤศจิกายน
อาตี๊พ.ศต.ยคะที่ผช
2564 ค่ะ
2564 นะคะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ
2  0
2152  021
2021 นะคะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันพุธทว่านี้เมื่อวานนี้วันพุธวันพุธ
วันพุธสีเขียวอาวุดเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 ค่ะวันที่ 24 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนที่ผชเท่าไหร่คะ 2555
464 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะสงฆ์
021 ค่ะโอเควันนี้นี้นะคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธอาบพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรค่ะครูฟ้าพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะลูกลุง
เอ๋วันศุกร์นะคะอ่ะวันศุกร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
วันที่ 26 ค่ะวันที่ 26 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายน aforce ตเท่าไหร่คะ
2564 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะหลง
021 ค่ะก็วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีสีส้ม
มี 2 องค์และเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
สีเขียว
เนาะ
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์สี
อาทิตย์ที่สีฟ้าก็ได้เนาะสีฟ้านะคะสีฟ้า
สีน้ำเงินโอเคนะคะโอเคได้กูเห็นลบนะคะลบ
ก่อนลบกวนรถลือ
อะไร
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
ตอนนี้นะคะเวลา
16:00 น
16:40 เล็กอีกเล็กไปอ่ะ
16:00 น 4
นาทีแต่มอง 44 นาทีโอ้ที่รักเธอเธอคือปี
4:44 นาที 16:00 นเอาเค.เน๊าะ
เย็น 16:00 นอ่ะสบายๆไม่ร้อนนะให้หมอนค่ะ
โอเคอ่าลบได้แล้วใช่ไหมคะถ้าคุณเอ๋
เคลียร์เลยกรีดลบค่ะลบ
ๆแล้วก็ Stop หยุด
โอเคดูเองขาครูเองสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะ
นิดหน่อยอ้าว
ไอนิดหน่อยไม่มี Hold  it ไม่มีไม่มีโค
วิชกูเองกินอาหารไม่ดี
น้อง
กูเอกกินหมูกินปลา 555 ก็จะ
ฆ่ากูเอเวนเจอร์สทัเรียนใช่ไหมหากิน
บล็อคโคลี่กินแครอทสบายๆ
วันนี้ครูเอกกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวหมู
ล่ะก็กิน
กินฮอทดอก
[เพลง]
ที่นี่
มีอะไรที่มีอะไรที่หรอๆไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยว
พูดพูดกับครูฟ้าเสร็จกูเองกินยา
ได้ค่ะคุณหนุ๋ยกินยาอาจสละแอนตี้ is ซา
มีนโอเค
ทีแรงแล้วสิบที่แล้วเราพูดถึง
ของใช้ทำจากอะไรใช่ไหมคะร้านป๋าชัยหาด
คลิปวีดีโอที่แล้วนะคะเราพูดของใช้ทำมา
จากพลาสติกทํามาจากสแตนเลสทำมาจาก
อะลูมิเนียม
ไฉนคลิปนี้เราจะพูดของใช้อีกเหมือนกัน
เนาะอะไรอ่ะคลิปวีดีโอนี้เราก็พูดของใช้ 5
ของใช้นะคะแต่
เราจะพูดว่าของใช้
ของไทยเนี่ยใช้ทำอะไรอ่ะ
ให้ตัว M กูเองไม่ของอันตรายถึงนั้นใช้ทำ
อะไรนะคะอะไรค่ะหน้า
ของครูเอกก็ได้ค่ะของครูเอ๋นะคะครูเหน่ง
นะฮะคู๋ make หวีหวี V ใช้ทำอะไรคะ
หวีใช้
หวีผมถ้าหากก็หมีผมอ่ะอ้ะฮึผมผมมือจับหวี
แล้วก็เอาหวีหวีผม
หวีผม
ถ้าไม่มีผมผมจะอย่างนี้ใช่ไหม
ถ้าไม่มีผมใช่อยากดูเอกผมเป็นอะไรครับคุณ
ฟ้าผมนะกลัวผมยุ่งอ่าผมยุ่งผมยุอาผมยุ่ง
ก็เอาหวีหวีผม
หวีผม
ใช่ไหมผม
ผมยาวข้าวสีผมมีผมผมสั้นแล้วผมสั้นผมสั้น
ก็หวีผมหน้าครูเอกยาวไหมคะผมยาวค่ะผมยาว
มากเดี๋ยวกูเองยืนนะคะ Tube  1 นายฮะโม้
ครูเอ๋ผม
ยาวผมยาวเพราะว่าครูเอ๋คิดตัดผมแต่
ร้านตัดผมปิด
รูวิทย์ไงถ้ากู with  salon ไม่มี salon
เลยใช่ไหมคะก็หวีผม
ผมเออเอ้ยหูฟ้าหวีผมไหมคะ
ไฟฟ้าไม่หวีผมน่ะเลยใช่ไหมคะ
ว่าฟ้าไม่มีหวี
ไม่มีหวีโครเอให้นี้ขอบคุณค่ะคุยได้หรือ
เวอรี่น่า
ให้เออกูฟ้าไม่มีหวีใช้นิ้วหาหาใช้นิ้ว
มือเออใช้นิ้ว World อ้าหวีผมแต่
ไอว่าค่ะหวีก็ใช้หวีผมรักน้ำ
ของกูฟ้ามีอะไรนะ
ของครูฟ้า
มีโทรศัพท์น่ะโทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์ใช้ทำอะไรคะ
โทรศัพท์ใช้โท
แล้วก็พูดอ้าวสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋ใช้ a ค่ะ
ครูอกหักสวัสดีค่ะหรือใช้ส่งข้อความค่ะ
ส่งข้อความก็ต้องมีอันนี้ใช่ไหมส่งข้อ
ความนะคะอ่า
หน่าส่งข้อความค่ะ
อาจจะมีใน LINE  WhatsApp หรือว่าอะไรอ่ะ
กล้าเก่าหอ
แอพพลิเคชั่นนะคะ
ไปทำอะไรครับหวี
ถ่ายรูป
อะไรรูปโทรศัพท์ใช้ถ่ายรูปได้อะนี่ไง
ใช่ใช้ถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายรูป
ให้ถ่ายรูปได้ด้วยเซลฟี่ก็ได้เนาะถ่ายรูป
ได้ฮะเล่นเกมมี่
ได้ไม่คุยได้เล่นเกมได้
เล่นเกมใช่มั้ยเล่นเกม FIFA มีเยอะเลยใช้
EM มากๆกรุ๊ป O ฟ้ารู้ไหมครูเอ๋ทำอะไร
อยู่ครูเอ๋ทำอะไรคะถ่ายวีดีโอ
ถ่ายวีดีโอให้อ่ะก็เดี๋ยวเปิดให้กูฟ้าดู
ได้ค่ะตัว f เปิดให้กูปลาดู
อิหยัง
เล่นวีดีโอวีดีโอ
ได้มากๆนะคะค่ะหวีใช้หวีผมแล้ว
ไม่โอเคโอเคเจ็บ
โอเคกุ้งฟ้ามีโทรศัพท์นะคะใช้ละใช้เล่น
เกมใช้โทรศัพท์ใช้ถ่ายรูปใช้ส่งข้อความ
ใช้ถ่าย vdo คือตัว A มีอะไรดี
วิถีมีอะไร
มีปากกา
[เพลง]
อากาจะทำอะไรคะ 8 กาเหรอคะปากการใช้ทำอัน
นี้เลยค่ะครูฟ้านี่เลยใช้เขียนปากกาใช้
เขียนไว้ใหญ่มาก
ปากกาใช้เขียน
ใช้เขียนแล้วก็ใช้วาดรูป
วาดรูปก็โอเค
วาดรูป
ลูก
[เพลง]
ใช้วาดรูปได้
ดีมากวาดรูปได้ด้วยฉาย
คะให้ทำอะไรได้อีกไหมคะหมดทำให้
ใช้เขียนใช้โอ๊ยลูกวัดลงประกาศใช้ 2
อย่างละเอียดกับวาดรูปนะคะกูฟ้าใช้ทำอะไร
กูวะใช้
ไปที่หู
ใส่ที่หูทำไมไอ้นี่โห
แต่บางคนเขาเขาใช้เขาม้วนผมใช้ผม
ได้ไว้กูมาทำได้ไหม
ใช้ระเบียบผม
ใช้เสียบผมนะใช้ปากกาเสียบผมได้นะคะ
แต่กูเอมีอะไรอีก
มีอะไรอีกมาเงี้ยไงกรรไกรเมื่อกี้กรรไกร
กรรไกร
ทั่วไปเนี่ยโคเอะนะกรรไกรใช้ตัดกระดาษใช่
ตัดอันนี้กระดาษแล้วกอล์ฟกับกระดาษ
ใช้ตัดกระดาษใช้ตัดผม
ตัดแม่
แป๊ะ
โอเคหนม
กับผมคือผม
ตอบสุด
ปุ่ม
A มีถังขยะ
คิดถึง
ถังขยะทำอ่าใช้ทิ้งขยะ 5 ถึงขยะช่วยหามี
ขยะ
พิษชู่นะค่ะใหญ่ๆน้ำขิงค่ะหญิงหละอ่ะ
ครูฟ้ามีอะไรคะยังยางรัดผมใช้ทำอะไรคะยาง
รัดผมใช้รัดผม
ไหมคะรัดผมค่ะ
ยางรัดผมนะคะใช้รัดผม
ดีมากสุดซอง
นะคะ
มีมีอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
ก็มีลิปสติกค่ะมีลิปสติกใช้ทำอะไรคะ
ลิปสติก
ลิปสติกหาใช้
ทาปากปากปาก
แล้วก็ทาทาให้ครูเอ๋ด้วยได้ไหมคะก็ได้ค่ะ
ครูเอ๋คุยถ้าปากอ้ะ
หาไว้หน้าตอนนี้อยู่ไกลกัน
ทาไม่ได้หากตาป่ะ
อาหาร
เมื่อกี้คุยมีกล่องดนตรีใช่ไหมคะ
กล่องดนตรีใช้ทำอะไรคะบุเขว้า
[เพลง]
ฟัง
มิเล่นดนตรีครูเอก of ฟัง the  way ฟัง
[เพลง]
ฟังดนตรีนะคะ
โอเคมั้ยโอเคนะ
ครูฟ้าอยากได้ยินมั้ยได้ยินค่ะเห็นนะคะ
หยุดชุดไม่หยุดไม่หยุดเดี๋ยวจะหยุด
กูไปละกูค่ะมีอะไรคะ
ถุงเท้าค่ะถุงเท้าใช้ทำอะไรคะ
ถุงเท้าใช้ใส่นิทานเอ้าที่เท้าขึ้นมา
ไม่ได้ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้เดี๋ยวกูเองว่าได้
อ้ะนะคะๆถุงเท้าถุงเท้านะคะอ่ะ
ลบอันนี้ก่อนเดี๋ยวผู้เอกว่าวาฬให้อ่ะก็
มีเท้า
มินิวส์ 2  3  4  5 มีเล็บ
เล็บเล็บเท้าเราก็ถุงเท้าสีฟ้าใช่ไหมคะสี
ฟ้า
สีฟ้าก็ถุงเท้า
ไม่ได้ใหญ่ไป
[เพลง]
ถุงเท้าก็
ใส่ที่
เท้า
ถึงเท้า
หรือยังเห็นนิ้วเลยเฮ้ยแม่
ปีที่ 4  through  A
ขอให้เห็นว่าไม่เห็นว่าใสที่เท้า
ถุงเท้านะคะ
ใส่ที่เท้า
ถุง
[เพลง]
เอามาทาง
ค่ะได้ๆ
ถุงเท้าติดอ่ะ
โอเคนะ 0 เท้าใส่ที่เท้าไม่เห็นเท้านะคะ
ไม่เห็นนะคะถ้าไม่ใส่ถุงเท้าก็จะเห็นเท้า
ชายโอเคนะคะ
ใส่ที่หมื่นได้ไหมถุงเท้า
ใส่มือให้ได้
ไม่ได้นะคะไม่จะได้ไม่ได้
รู้เอมิอะไรเอกเดี๋ยวผู้อื่นดูก่อนนะคะ
ครูเอมอี
ไปแชะๆๆไปแทะไปเช๊คใช้ทำอะไรคะครูป่ากู
เห็น Stock  chaz วินแบบอุ้ย
นักเรียนไม่เห็นใช่มั้ยไม่เห็น
ไปแท็กใช้โอเคไหมเนี่ย
ใช้จุดไฟชุบ
จุดไปมีกระดาษไม่ได้นะ
ใช้จุดไฟนะคะไฟชัดใช้จุดไฟ
ไปชักนิดนึงนะคะค่ะทีนี่ห่าอะไรคะอะไร
มี
อะไรหูฟัง
หูฟังแฟนใช้ทำอะไรคะหูฟังใช้
ฟังเพลงค่ะค่ะใส่
ฟังเพลงเพลงอยู่ที่ไหน
โทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์ใช้ฟังเพลงได้
ใช่ค่ะโทรศัพท์ใช้ฟังเพลงได้นะอ่าใช่ไหม
สมมติ
มีเพลงเขาก็มีหูฟัง
ฟังเพลง
ครูฟ้าก็จะได้ฟังเพลงคนเดียวคนเดียวหาพ่อ
ถ้าไม่ใช้หูฟัง
ก็ได้
จะ
เห็นว่าจะได้ยินอ๋อทุกคนจะได้ยินนะได้ยิน
โครงฟ้าใส่หูฟังทุกคนไม่ได้ยินไม่ได้ยิน
โรฟ้าได้ยินคนเดียวใครฟังเพลงคนเดียวรักๆ
ๆ
เห็นไหมกูเอง
ก็เห็นมีอะไรคะแหวน
แหวน
แว่นใช้ทำอะไรใช้ใส่หูได้ไหมคะ
แหวนใช้ใส่ที่นิ้ว R
ใส่ที่นิ้ว
ใช้ใส่ที่นิ้วเวลามีคนเห็นอ้อแต่งงาน
งานแต่งงานแล้วแล้วครูเอ๋ก็ได้เอาแหวนออก
ใส่ใส่นะคะ
ที่นิ้วที่นิ้วที่นิ้ว
ก็ A มีอะไรอีกเมื่อกี้คู๋พูดถึงกันไกล
ใช่ไหมคะกันไก่กรรไกรตัดเล็บ
กรรไกรตัดเล็บค่ะหายอะไรคะครูเอ๋ Ice ตัด
เล็บ
มีเล็บแล้วก็
ตัด
น้ำตัด
เล็บเท่
นี้นะคะก็ใช้ตัดเล็บราคาอ่าโอเค
ค่ะมีปากกา
ปากกาไวท์บอร์ด
ไอห่า r9 ไวท์บอร์ด
ประกายเขียนใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะใช้เขียน
ปากกาใช้เขียนค่ะเขียนนะค่ะ
อยากแล้วฝาปากกาใช้ทำอะไรคะป๋าปากกาค่ะ
ใช้มันติดชัด
ปิดค่ะ
ใช้
ฝา
ไม่มีฝาโอเคมั้ยไม่มีฝา
แอบเพื่อๆถ้าไม่มีฝา
เขียนไม่ได้แต่ไม่มีปัญหาเขียนไม่ได้ไม่
ได้ต้องมีฝาปิดราคาปิดไว้ปิด
[เพลง]
คู๋มีอะไรอีก
ฟันลบได้ค่ะได้ได้
กู a  Me  and นี้
อันนี้คืออะไรคะครูเอ๋คลิป
กิ๊บหนีบผมกิ๊บติดผมได้ติดผมใจมีผมใช่
มั้ยแล้วก็
ไปข้างหลังนะถ้าทำยังไงอันนี้ก็ได้ค่ะ
คลิปติดผมกิ๊บสิกหุมมีเงินสวยไหมคะผู้ฟ้า
สวยค่ะคุณเอ๋
ในคลิปใช่ไหมคะสวย
คลิป
เกมส์สวยๆๆ
ถ้ามี
ลูกค้าก่อนค่ะไม่มีถุงพลาสติกเฉยๆค่ะแค่
เสียงใช้ทำอะไรคะถุงพลาสติกใช้ใส่ของนะ
เวลานักเรียนมีของคือใส่
ของใส่ของใส่ของใส่ของนะถุงพลาสติกขายเขา
ใส่ของได้ครูเอมีอันนี้ครับผมฟ้าอะไรคะ
พูดเอ๋ยี่ห้อ
Lexus เอาไว้ทำอะไรเอาไว้
ใช้ทำอะไรเช็ดแว่นตา
โอ๊ตเช็ดแว่นตาเสร็จแว่นตาเขาเรียกว่าผ้า
เช็ดแว่นตา
ผ้าเช็ดแว่นตาก็ใช้เช็ดแว่นตา
ดีมากเลยผ้าเช็ดแว่นป่านะฟรีอะไรแล้วก็
ami อีกมีอะไรอีกครั้งคู๋ตัวเองมีอันนี้
ขับตำรับ
ต้นบัตร
ไว้ทำอะไรคะภูฟ้า
แพะหมูก็
แคะโห
หนูแค่จมูกได้ไหม
แฮชจมูกมันไม่โอเคนะไม่ได้แล้วแค่
หูเนอะแคะเสร็จหมูก็ได้เช็ดถู
เช็ดหูหรือว่าแคะหูค่ะซูมโอ้นี่นี่ค่ะนี่
อะไรคะไดร์ฟเป่าผมเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะไว้เป่า
เสื้อ
ไม่ใช่ไดร์ฟเป่าผมใช้เป่าผมหรือมีผมมีไป
ไดร์เป่าผม
เป่า
ๆนะใช้เป่าผมเป่าผม
R5 ค่ะผมยาวโอเคนะใครหวีด้วยนะครูฟ้า
มีใดใช้กับหวีใต้ก็สีแล้วก็ไดร์
[เพลง]
ผมจะตรงสวย
โปรฟ้ามีไดร์เป่าผมครูเอ๋มีหวีไม่มีไดร์
เป่าผม
อกหักจะทำยังไง
มีกระดาษ
มินิผ้ามีค่าแล้วก็เทพ
เช็ดผมเช็ดผมโอเคแล้วก็มีพัดลม
พี่มีพัดลมนะคะเมียตัวนี้
ตัวเองให้ดู
มีพัดลม
[เพลง]
พัดลม
ครูเอ๋วาดลม
เวลาวาดพัดลม
เอางู
ผมพัดลมโอเคแค่แห้ง
ดีบ้านเลยค่ะ
ลง
คลิปนี้นักเรียนก็รู้ว่าหวีใช้หวีผมขับ
ช้า
จะใช้ทำอะไรนะคะปากกาใช้เขียนใช้เขียนใช้
วาดนะคะ
กิ๊บติดผม
ใช้อิฐผมนะคะ
ยางรัดผมใช้ใช่ทำอะไรคะรัดผมใช้รัดผม
โทรศัพท์ใช้ทำอะไรคะ
โทรศัพท์อยู่ที่ไหนคะ
ใครโทรใช้โทใช้ถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปถ่ายวีดีโอ
เล่นเกมส์
ส่งข้อความแชทสงเคราะห์ให้ฟันเพลงฟัง
หูฟัง
หายฟังเพลงใช้ฟังโทรศัพท์นะคะ
ถุงเท้าใช้อ่ะใส่ในขาวขาวนะถุงเท้าใส่
เท้าลิฟฟิกใช้ทำอะไรคะทาปากใช้ทาปาก
ไปแค๊กใช้จุดไฟจุดไผ่วัดเดี๋ยวนะถ้าโดนผม
เนี่ยไม่มี
กรรไกรกรรไกร
ใช้ตับชัดใช้กับนะค่ะๆไล่ตัดเล็บกรรไกร
ตัดเล็บ
ก็ใช้ตัดเล็บนะคะๆ
คัตเติ้ลบาท
บาทกะใช้แค่หูแค่โขเช็ดโขนะคะอ่า
แล้วก็ทิ้งๆมีซิงค์ 2 อันแล้ว
ทิ้งขยะ
ถังขยะ
ขยะค่าใช้ทิ้งขยะใช้ทิ้งขยะ
ผ้าเช็ดแว่นตา
ใช้เชฟแว่นตาราคา
ก็คลิปนี้เนาะรุ่นหมดแล้วนะคะหมดเวลาแล้ว
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าชายท่านแฟนอยากจะฟัง
ภาษาไทยจากครูฟ้าครูเอ๋ทำยังไงคะก็ต้องกด
Subscribe ก็หาแล้วก็กดไลค์กดแชร์ด้วยนะ
คะนักเรียนคอมเม้นนะคะนักเรียนมีหวีไหม
ทีวีไหมกูฟ้ามีไรครูเอ๋มีหวีนะคะเตะๆค่ะ
แต่ถ้าคดีก็เป็นฟ้าเอาขึ้นค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนไปบ้างอ่ะ